The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Perfect timing.
Let's turn to the
announcements.
You know the big announcement
is Monday,
Celebration Part three.
I think Hilary sent all
of you the coverage.
Just to be clear, start with
defects, amorphous solids,
kinetics, diffusions, solutions,
acids, and bases.
No orgo, no polymers.
We'll catch the orgo and the
polymers on the celebration of
celebrations, the final exam.
OK, so let's get moving.
Last day we started talking
about polymers.
These are macromolecules.
Here we've got an example of a
simple compound with a double
bond, vinyl chloride.
And by the action of addition
polymerization, we can turn
this into a macromolecule where
you see a repeat unit.
The double bond has been broken
to allow but carbon to
bond to another vinyl
chloride, and so on.
These are very, very large
molecules, can be on the order
of microns in length, mass
measured in kilodaltons, or
thousands of grams per mole.
So today I want to go back
and look a little
bit at polymer synthesis.
Then we're going to talk about
properties of polymers, and
end with some cultural
implications that I alluded to
the very beginning.
So we've already seen how this
reaction begins, but let's see
how it proceeds.
So here's an example of starting
with an initiation
reaction that generates this
hydroxyl radical that starts
from a peroxide.
And then you can see, in this
first instance, the unpaired
electron attacks the double
bond, breaks the double bond
links, and then moves that
unpaired electron to the end,
and so on, and so on.
So here I'm indicating that
we're going to keep attaching,
in this case, ethylenes
to make polyethylene.
And then at some point, we
decide that we've got the
molecule long enough,
and then we have
to quench the reaction.
So then we add something that
will cap this unpaired
electron, and this step
is called termination.
So this is how we make the
long-chain molecules by this
particular reaction.
And the thing to know,
trivially, is that the
composition of the polymer
equals the
composition of the mer.
You can see it right
here, that I
start with vinyl chloride.
Yeah, we've changed the double
bond to a single bond, but
it's still C2H3Cl, C2H3Cl
taken many times.
That's it.
OK.
There's another way
to make polymers.
And this is really important,
not only in commerce, but it's
most important in biology.
We do not have the biological
apparatus to create radicals.
So during the course of this
lecture, we have cell death
proceeding in all of us,
and cell generation and
polymerization reactions
occurring, amino acids being
linked to form proteins
and whatnot.
And that process goes by the
second mechanism, condensation
polymerization.
And I'll give you a simple
example of that where we start
with more than one mer, OK?
Involves more than
one mer type.
Typically two, all right?
So let's look at a reaction.
So this is going to be a first
kind of a mer, and R is just a
general placeholder the people
use in organic chemistry.
It comes from the word residual,
but it's some giant
piece of molecular mass, and
there's a hydrogen here.
And this one then reacts with a
second mer, which I'm going
to designate R2.
And the second mer
has a hydroxyl.
And what happens in condensation
polymerization,
is that we link R1 to R2.
R1 is now linked to R2
in a covalent manner.
And then, we take the hydrogen
and the hydroxyl, and we send
them over here.
So the hydrogen goes here,
the hydroxyl goes
here, to form water.
And this is typically conducted,
in industry, not in
our bodies, but in industry,
it's typically conducted at
elevated temperatures where this
eventually goes into some
kind of a condenser.
And then the water condenses
and makes liquid.
And for this step, the
condensation step of the
byproduct of the reaction that
we name the process.
The process isn't named
for what happens here.
It's named for what
happens over here.
So this is condensation
polymerization, and you can
see, we have covalent linkages
at both ends, and we can add
another R1H here, and then
another R2OH here, and so on,
and so on, and so on.
So clearly, we're losing
some of the mass of
the reactants here.
So the mass of the final polymer
is less than the sum
of the masses of all
of the reagents.
So let's make a note of that.
That the mass of the polymer
formed by condensation
polymerization is less than the
sum of the masses of the
constituents.
Or let's say reactants,
if we like.
Reactants.
Because we lose the
condensate.
And so here's an example
from commerce.
Oh, before I get to that, I
wanted to show you some of the
common addition polymers,
which ones that you're
familiar with that are made
by this first process.
So at the top, we have
polyethylene.
That's we started with.
And you know that's used in food
wrap, it's used in milk
jugs, and so on.
There's the
polytetrafluoroethylene.
You remove the hydrogens, you
put fluorines, and then you
make Teflon.
So that's also made
by addition.
Polypropylene, also
used as separator.
In fact, polypropylene
is found in
every lithium ion battery.
It's the separator between the
two electrodes, and it's
engineered so that its glass
transition temperature is
about 60, 70 degrees Celsius.
So that if there's some event,
and you start getting thermal
runaway in your battery, and
the temperature rises to
whatever, let's say the number
is 70 degrees C, the pores in
the polypropylene collapse.
And when they collapse, they
form a barrier, and it kills
the battery, and prevents the
battery from exploding.
And that's polypropylene.
There's butyl rubber.
What else do we have?
Polystyrene, you know, which is
used in these cups and food
containers.
Orlon, here.
Polyvinyl chloride, which is
used in everything from old
vinyl phonograph records
to plumbing supplies.
That white PVC tubing that's
used for piping.
Polymethyl methacrylate, this
is plexiglass, which many of
you are wearing in
your eyeglasses.
That's this material here.
Butadiene, OK.
You see there's the
after-polymerization.
There's still one unused double
bond, so then we can
mix this later on for
cross-linking.
And the various rubbers,
and so on.
You can see, they all have
residual double bonds, which
allows them to then participate
in disulfide linkages.
OK.
So now here's the example I
wanted to show you that you
will be familiar with
in commerce.
This is the PET, the
polyethylene terephthalate,
the plastic bottles.
The two-liter soda bottles
are made of this stuff.
So you start with this thing,
which is known industrially as
terephthalic acid, which
is really 1-4-benzene.
You see the benzene ring here,
so one, two, three, four.
So off the one position and the
four position, you have a
carboxylic acid, and this
is critical in proteins.
You're going to see the COOH
structure over and over again.
And that H is detachable.
So this, then, it becomes
a proton donor.
If it's a proton donor,
it's an acid.
So this is the
1-4-benzenedicarboxylic acid.
And this is ethylene glycol,
which you know as the base
constituent of antifreeze
for automobiles.
It's really ethane with
two alcohols.
So it's a diol.
Ethanediol, 1-2.
And you mix the ethanediol with
the terephthalic acid,
spit off the proton and the
hydroxyl, leaving behind this,
which then forms the bridge
here, and there's the basis
for the plastic soda bottle.
This is the same material from
which you can make Dacron,
which is a fiber used sometimes
in textiles, and
Mylar, which is used in sheet
films for polymer films. So
this is the PET.
And note here, you see this
oxygen is acting as a bridge.
It's acting as a bridge between
the terephthalic acid
residual and the ethylene
glycol residual.
So again, we see nature relying
on the fact that
oxygen forms those two bonds and
acts as a bridge for us.
OK.
A couple of other
things to note.
Here are the typical polymers
that are made by condensation
polymerization.
All of the nylons.
The nylons are made by
condensation polymerization.
And the bond here that exists
between the nitrogen and the
carbon is called
the amide bond.
Even though it's spelled A M I
D E, it's pronounced amid.
So these are all nylons.
The generic term
is polyamides.
And you see the different
types of nylon here.
Kevlar, used as a substitute
for steel belting in tires,
derives its strength from this,
the benzene ring here.
And polyesters, OK?
The Dacron, the Mylar, I
just showed you that.
Lexan.
This is used in everything from
sports equipment, if you
wear eyeglasses in
sports, they're
probably made of Lexan.
Again, look at these twin
benzene rings, and then you've
got the linkage on
the end here.
And also used when you're
sitting seven miles above the
surface of the earth.
The only thing that prevents you
from being asphyxiated or
frozen to death in that
airplane is a
window made of Lexan.
And lastly, here are the
silicones, which are also made
by condensation polymerization.
And just a little note
here for you.
The person who invented
the silicones
didn't know his chemistry.
And he thought that the
silicone, in fact, had a
double bond here.
See, this is acetone, and
it from comes from
the family of ketones.
So you have methyl above, methyl
below, carbon, and a
double bond off to the side.
Well, it turns out
that silicone
doesn't form double bonds.
Everybody in 3.091 knows this.
It's too big.
So it only has a single bond.
If it's a single bond,
it's not an -one.
It's just like a pentane,
methane, so on.
So this should be a siloxane.
So what people refer to as
silicones today properly are
called siloxanes.
OK.
Another thing to note.
Let's go back to the--
you see here?
We go down the backbone
of the nylon, there's
the carboxylic acid.
And there's a C with a double
bond to the O, and it spit off
its H, right?
That was the proton donor.
Look at over here.
There's an amino group here,
a nitrogen with a hydrogen.
Well, if I line those
two up just right,
look at what can happen.
Here's a carbon-oxygen, and
here's a nitrogen-hydrogen.
What do you know if you've
got hydrogen
sitting next to an oxygen?
It can form hydrogen bonds.
And so nylons derive their
higher strength from the
hydrogen bonds that form
between the chains.
Doesn't this remind you
of cross-linking?
It's sort of same church,
different pew.
It's not as strong as a
disulfite covalent linkage,
but it does form linkages.
That's good.
It's good because it
gives you strength.
But it doesn't come with the
penalty that cross-linking
comes with.
And what's the penalty?
You can't recycle cross- linked
polymers very easily,
because you've got these
strong covalent
bonds in the chains.
If you heat the polymer up,
those bonds don't break.
If you heat this up, the
hydrogen bonds will let go.
And you can remelt nylons, you
can recycle those polymers
much more easily.
So I want to make another
taxonomy here that
distinguishes polymers
on the basis of their
ability to be recycled.
Very important these days.
One of the first questions
people ask if you're using a
polymer in a process,
is it recyclable?
And what do you do?
You start thinking about the
molecular architecture in
order to answer that question.
OK.
So let's talk about the ones
that can be recycled.
So recyclable ones are called
thermoplastics.
Weak van der Waals and
hydrogen bonds only.
And this is between
the chains.
You don't break the bonds up
and down the backbone.
If you break the blinds up and
down the backbone, you'll
pyrolyze the material.
If you go to a high enough
temperature to break covalent
bonds in the backbone of a
polymer, you're on fire.
So don't go there, all right?
So hydrogen bonds only, so this
can reheat and reprocess.
So now we're talking about
something that's almost like
recycling metal.
You remelt it and reuse it.
The ones that have the strong
covalent linkages are called
thermal sets.
And the thermal set is
difficult to recycle.
This is cross-linked--
difficult.
Notice I'm not writing
impossible.
It's difficult to recycle,
which is a polite way of
saying, you can do it,
and it's really
expensive to do so.
You might be better off to just
start with virgin material.
By the way, where do we
get the material?
How do we make polymers?
Where do we get this
carbon from?
From petroleum.
You say, well, why don't
we use coal?
Well, you need carbon and
hydrogen in these systems. And
coal is carbon.
Petroleum is hydrocarbon.
So these are petroleum-derived.
So all these questions about
resource utilization and so on
come right up in center stage.
OK.
Now I want to take a few minutes
to talk about use of
crystallization to strengthen
polymers, OK?
So crystallization for
mechanical performance.
We want to improve the
And I alluded to
this last day.
We;ll do this really quickly.
So we've seen that if we want
to, we know that if we--
let me give you the
little icon here.
So you're going along like
this, and some nice, long
chain, and all of a sudden,
you get a zone of
crystallinity.
So I'm talking about adding
crystallinity in order to
strengthen the material.
And so we know that this has
more bond density than the
straight chain here, so this
is going to be stronger.
So if I want to strengthen the
polymer, introduce more
crystallization, so what
favors the onset of
crystallization?
Or we'll say, partial
crystallization.
The whole thing doesn't
turn into a crystal.
To favor crystallization, what
do we do with the various set
points that we have
in the material?
Well, first of all, we know with
composition, composition
is one of our levers.
And we want to make
it uniform.
So that means homopolymer is
favored over the copolymer.
Or maybe there are other
instances where you don't want
crystallinity.
In the soles of your running
shoe, you don't want that
turning into something
that's semibrittle.
You want it to be soft.
So that's why we use copolymers
in the soles of
running shoes, in order
to disfavor.
And if we want to do something
like those jewel cases that I
keep railing against, the jewel
cases are a homopolymer
that have a fair bit
of crystallinity.
The second one we talked about
last day, tacticity, this is a
second lever that you have.
So we know that
isotactic over atactic.
The more uniform, the more
likely the material will be to
crystallize.
So the isotactic polystyrene
makes those jewel boxes,
whereas the atactic polystyrene
makes the food
containers that you get
when you buy food from
the trucks out here.
And number three, we talked
about conformation.
And we know that
conformation--
linear over branched, right?
Linear over branched.
If we have a branched polymer,
it's not going to pack very
well, so it's less likely
to crystallize.
The linear one, as I've
demonstrated in this cartoon,
has a much, much higher
propensity for
crystallization.
All right.
How about properties?
Let's talk about properties.
Properties of polymers.
And I'm talking here about the
bulk commodity polymers.
Sure, you can find specialty
polymers that have remarkable
properties that aren't
characteristic of polymers,
but I'm not talking
about those.
So first of all.
Electrical properties.
They're insulators, electrical
insulators.
Why are they electrical
insulators?
We're talking about mainly
covalent bonds here.
Covalent bonds, which means
tightly bound electrons,
tightly bound and localized,
because you saw that in
graphite, they're tightly
bound, but they're
delocalized.
So tightly bound electrons.
And no ions, because we've now
recognized that we can conduct
electricity not only by
electrons, but by ions.
Tightly bound electrons,
no ions.
That means no carriers, that
means no connectivity.
Number two.
What's the second property?
Transparent to visible light.
Again, same thing.
Tightly bound electrons, not
possible to excite, et cetera.
So these are clear,
and furthermore,
are generally colorless.
And this is especially in the
case of amorphous materials.
Amorphous materials are
clear, colorless.
What happens if we get
semicrystallization?
Those crystalline zones, as I
showed you last day, those
crystalline zones are clear and
colorless as well, but the
index of refraction of the
crystalline zone is not equal
to the index of refraction of
the amorphous zone, and so
this boundary, if you will,
scatters light.
So we have two clear and
colorless zones of different
index, and so if we put them
together, we end up with
something that is opaque, and
that's in the case of the
crystallinity.
When you have some
crystallinity,
you'll give up on that.
And actually, I wanted to show
you a few things from the
popular culture.
So I think what I've
got here--
oh, these are the-- yeah, OK.
This is a little scene from
the musical Chicago.
It's Mr. Cellophane.
Cellophane is polymer,
viscose.
All right?
Listen to the properties.
They get it right.
[MUSIC PLAYBACK]
-I tell you Cellophane, Mr.
Cellophane, should I bend my
name, Mr. Cellophane.
Because you can look right
through me, walk right by me,
and never know I'm there.
-Oh, I didn't see you.
[END MUSIC PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So sometimes the popular
culture gets it right.
All right.
So now, what's the third
property of polymers?
Chemically inert.
And this is why we use them in
food packaging, and also in
other forms of packaging.
Again, strong bonds, strong
covalent bonds, means that
it's not very reactive with
the contents of many
containers, including
foods and beverages.
A fourth property that's
exploited in polymers is very
low density.
Why?
Well, what are the constituents
of the polymers?
Contains things like
carbon, nitrogen--
well, let's put carbon and
hydrogen first. Those are the
two biggies.
So we've got carbon
and hydrogen.
You saw some nitrogen, oxygen,
and then trace levels of other
substances.
So these are all
low Z elements.
So for example, in a
beverage container.
I can make a beverage
container.
You see a beverage container.
I see a bundle of properties.
What is the bundle
of properties?
It has to be some physical
rigidity, but not much,
because I can squeeze this.
It's OK.
And it has to be chemically
inert with
respect to its contents.
So I could build this out
of a borosilicate
glass, a glass bottle.
And the density of borosilicate
glass is about 3.54.
Or I can make it out of
aluminum, and the density of
the aluminum is about 2.7.
Or I can make it out of polymer,
and the density is
down close to 1.
So now if I load up the beverage
truck, instead of
transporting the contents plus
the mass of the container, the
higher fraction now is just
the contents, and the
container weighs less.
When I was your age,
we had still soda
cans made out of steel.
Steel soda cans.
Yeah.
They didn't have pull tops.
You had to have an opener
to open them.
And the density of
steel is 7.87.
Iron is 7.87.
So from steel, down to this,
down to this, and so on.
So you see the low density
has an advantage.
But, you know, we're going to
have to go back over here and
start thinking about
recyclability.
So you see the balancing act
here in choosing materials.
You can't just seize upon one
attribute and say, oh, this is
less dense than that,
let's go with it.
But it's made from petroleum,
and maybe it's not so
recyclable.
So now what do you do?
Maybe you do make it out of
steel, because you know, what
you can recycle steel.
You can take the door off a 1928
Model-T Ford, melt that
door down, and you can put
it on a 2010 Taurus.
That's how recyclable iron is.
I'm just telling you what
the properties are.
You're going to have to make
the tough decisions.
And five, solid at
room temperature.
And why are they solid
at room temperature?
Because the interchain bonds,
even though they're weak, they
have a long, long, long, long
surface contact area.
So entanglement of van
der Waals bonds.
So you have the best
of both worlds.
It's solid at room temperature,
but in the case
of a thermal plastic with
modest heating, you can
restore back to the
original case.
Oh.
Here I have, I found
the Polythene Pam.
I'll play you just a
little segment of
it, the first verse.
The interesting thing to listen
to, in many of the
Beatles songs, you
can't tell this.
In the song, you
can really tell
the accent from Liverpool.
Listen carefully.
You'll hear the pronunciation.
That Merseyside accent.
And the way they're playing
is the old skiffle.
This is how they started,
in the clubs in
Hamburg and so on.
This is this is not
advanced Beatles.
They were playing here, it's
sort of little joke in the
middle of the Abbey
Road album.
They go retro and show the way
they were when they first
formed the band.
[AUDIO CLIP REMOVED ]
PROFESSOR: Did you catch that?
The Liverpudlian accent?
It comes complete with
the glottal stop?
[IMITATING ACCENT]
You know how you eat the tea?
Give me a bottle?
Yeah.
That's all from Liverpool.
Merseyside.
OK.
So now what do I have here?
Oh, here's recyclability
codes.
Throw this in, you know,
it's a part of
the part of the pack.
So there's the polyethylene
terephthalate,
that I've shown you.
This is high-density
polyethylene, PVC, low-density
polyethylene, and so on.
And look here.
Invented by, invented by,
invented by, invented by.
These are all man-made
materials.
They didn't exist before.
Keep going.
Invented by, invented by.
And they're all invented
in the 20th
century, with one exception.
A pharmacist in Germany by the
name of Eduard Simon was
playing with the vinyl benzene
and managed to make this goo
that became what we know
as polystyrene.
And nobody could explain.
Remember, in 18--
he was doing this in 1839,
before Kekule had even
speculated that you can get
carbon-carbon linkages!
No benzene rings!
So that he was linking benzene,
that they didn't even
understand existed as a ring,
and he was making polymers
that they didn't appreciate
that you could even make
C17H36, let alone C10,017.
So in 1922, Hermann Staudinger
gave the explanation that what
we're seeing here is the
polymerization into
macromolecules.
And for that, he got the
Nobel Prize in 1953.
Note, it took 30 years.
You don't invent something
that's really, really
prize-winning, and on the way
home, turn on the radio and
discover, oh, I won
the Nobel Prize.
It takes time.
And especially, the more
remarkable the discovery, it
takes time before people
accept it and say,
this is not a hoax.
This is real.
They didn't have the
characterization.
How were they going
to verify in 1922?
So you keep waiting,
waiting, waiting.
Look at what happened
to de Broglie.
De Broglie said, lambda
equals h over p,
and they went, uh-huh.
And then, as soon as the fellows
did the experiment
down at Bell Labs and they
got electron defraction--
boom!
He gets the Nobel Prize.
They said, you know what?
You're right!
That's how it works.
OK.
This was one of the giants.
This was Wallace Carothers.
Carothers, who for
a short time was
a lecturer at Harvard.
He left Harvard and joined
DuPont, and he gave birth to
an incredible array of synthetic
materials, as they
say here, similar to cellulose
and silicon.
Invented neoprene, the first
synthetic rubber.
This was very important for
the United States and the
Allied Powers during World War
II, because we did not have
access to natural rubber.
And the fact that they were
making synthetic rubber here
from materials that we had here
allowed us to continue
building for the war effort.
Invented nylon, in 1937.
An amazing man.
Unfortunately deeply troubled,
very depressive.
And two days after his 41st
birthday, he checked in a
hotel in Philadelphia, and
took his own life.
This is Wallace Carothers.
So I'm going to show you
now some synthesis.
About ten years ago, I had a
live demonstration here.
There was a gal who was doing
her PhD over here in Building
13, and she'd come in
and do these demos.
But, you know, it's been
ten years now.
We let her graduate, so she's
not around anymore.
So we took some videos of it.
So the first thing I want
to show you is the
synthesis of nylon.
So you're going to see
this reaction.
So in this case, it's
hexamethylene diamine and
adipic acid.
And that's going to give you
nylon-6,6 plus water, just as
this reaction indicates here,
and these are immiscible.
See, the adipic acid is in
aqueous phase, and the
hexamethylene diamine is a
non-aqueous phase, so they
form two phases right here, two
liquid layers, and this
reaction occurs at
the interface
between the two layers.
So you're going to see a close
up of the beaker, and she's
going to now dip an
instrument in, and
start pulling the solid.
She's making the solid from two
liquids, and she's going
to pull it.
And as she pulls it, she
clears the interface.
Because once the interface
is covered, new
reactant can't get there.
So ironically, the product
separates the two halves of
the reaction from each other.
So you have to get
the product out.
This is really cool.
So there's the chemistry.
So let's look.
This is Heidi Burch.
David, could we dim
the lights, maybe?
[FILM PLAYBACK]
HEIDI BURCH: The derivative of
a carboxylic acid then is
mercuric chloride.
I have it dissolved in hexane.
My base is hexamethylene
diamine, and I've got it
dissolved in water.
So to do this right, I have
to make them float.
So we're going to pour,
if I can get it open.
PROFESSOR: This is the
old 10-250, too.
It's got a carpet here.
HEIDI BURCH: --because it's
dissolved in water, which has
a higher density than hexane.
And then I have my acid
dissolved in the hexane.
So what's going to happen
when I pour that in?
It's not going to mix, right?
PROFESSOR: It'll separate.
HEIDI BURCH: It's going to
phase separate, exactly.
And we're going to
have strata.
Is that going to help or
hurt our reaction?
It's going to hurt our
reaction, right?
To have a good reaction, you
need intimate mixing.
Well--
PROFESSOR: This is like
the Uzo water problem.
HEIDI BURCH: So this is pretty,
actually pretty
unexciting.
Nothing really interesting
has happened.
It's just kind of
sitting there.
Nothing's exploding out of the
beaker, nothing's coming out.
It's kind of tame.
But if you look carefully,
you can kind of see--
where did my pointer go?
You can kind of see this
film right there.
See that big bubble?
Well, there's a scum that's
floating at the interface
between the two layers.
That's actually the nylon
that we formed.
What happens is, I mentioned
that nylon has that excellent
chemical resistance.
Well, when we formed it, it made
a barrier film between
the two layers so that no more
reactants could get through to
each other to form
more nylons.
So what I have to do is remove
that barrier film to allow the
reactants to come
into contact.
And I'm doing that by drawing
off the nylon as it's formed.
Because I'm drawing off the
film, are very haphazard.
And what's happening is, the
polymer I'm forming has a very
broad molecular weight
distribution.
It's not all 240 grams
per mole or whatever.
And that greatly affects the
mechanical properties, and, in
fact, it affects them
detrimentally.
So the mechanical properties of
this nylon that I'm forming
aren't very good.
[END FILM PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So that's the first one.
Now, the second one I'm going to
show you talks about glass
transition temperature, and
how you engineer a rubber.
So it might shock you to
know that a rubber
is, in fact, a liquid.
It's a polymer that's above
its glass transition
temperature.
It might be supercooled liquid,
but it's liquid.
And those disulfide linkages
give you the flexibility so
that the chains can move
against one another.
If you drop the temperature
below the glass transition
temperature, the whole thing
turns into an amorphous solid.
So what are the mechanical
properties?
What I'm indicating here
is the ball, all right?
So the bouncing ball is up
here, above the glass
transition temperature
it's cross-linked and
behaves as an elastomer.
If you get the temperature too
low, you'll end up solidifying
everything, and then it turns
into something with the
mechanical properties of a
billiard ball, all right?
So we call that tough.
Tough means it has impact
resistance.
It will absorb a
lot of energy.
So if I drop the ball, it won't
bounce, it takes the
energy of falling and absorbs
it and holds it.
So if you want a ball
to bounce, you
want to be above here.
So what we're going to do, is
we're going to take two
different polymers.
One that at room temperature is
here, and one that at room
temperature is here.
The one that's down here, we're
going to put in the
boiling water and get
it over here.
The one that is naturally a
bouncer here, we're going to
put into liquid nitrogen
and send it over here.
So we're going to make a
bouncing ball not bounce, and
we're going to make a flat
unbouncy ball bounce.
We're going to teach
these balls.
And what are we going to do?
We're going to teach these balls
how to bounce and not
bounce on temperature cue, by
moving on opposite sides of
the glass transition
temperature.
So this is a glass, and this
over here is a rubber, OK?
All right.
So here they are.
Those are the two rubbers.
One is norbornene, and the
other is isoprene.
And both of these, if you go
back to the earlier slides,
have a double bond in the
polymer, And that double bond
has now been broken for
disulfide linkages.
This is Heidi again.
[FILM PLAYBACK]
HEIDI BURCH: OK.
The thing I want to talk about
now, is the effect of
temperature on polymer
molecules.
Basically, when do I get rubbery
behavior and when do I
get glassy behavior?
Because I can get the same
polymer to exhibit rubbery
behavior or glassy behavior,
depending on the temperature
at which I use that material.
As Dr. Sadoway told you,
polymers have what's called a
glass transition temperature,
and the type of behavior that
I get is determined by my use
temperature relative to my
glass transition temperature.
So I have here six
little balls with
faces painted on them.
The ones with the happy faces
are polyisoprene.
The ones with the sad faces
are polynorbornene.
Now, polynorbornene is a
synthetic rubber that was
developed during World War II
when we didn't have access to
all the rubber tree groves
in Southeast Asia.
So the happy balls are happy
because their glass transition
temperature is minus 67.
So our use temperature at room
temperature is much greater
that their glass transition
temperatures, so they behave
as rubber would.
The polynorbornene has a glass
transition temperature of 40.
So we're actually below its
glass transition temperature
at room temperature,
and it just
dissipates all the energy.
We get a much more glassy-like
behavior from this material,
and it doesn't bounce.
So what we can do here to
demonstrate the effect is
we're going raise the use
temperature of both materials,
and we're going to
lower the use
temperature of both materials.
So I'm going to drop them in
boiling water, and hope that
the little faces stay on,
because I just painted them on
with white-out.
I don't know how that's
going to work.
And then I'm going to drop two
of them in liquid nitrogen.
Now, these will be
our controls.
Remember, polynorbornene,
polyisoprene.
Now something to think about,
which I know Dr. Sadoway
always likes to ask, is why
does one have a high glass
transition temperature, and why
does one have a low glass
transition temperature?
And I'll leave you to ponder
that little conundrum, while I
try to fish these
bad boys out.
OK.
Oh!
White-out worked.
So this is the polyisoprene.
Can you hear the sound
that it makes?
When I drop the one that's at
room temperature, I get a nice
rubbery sound.
When I drop that one, I get a
plastic, hard glassy sound.
I've cooled it below its glass
transition temperature, and
now I get a totally glassy
impact, like if I were
knocking pool balls together.
Now let's go in for the
polynorbornene.
Oh!
His eye came off.
Same thing.
I pulled the polynorbornene
below its glass transition
temperature as well, so it,
too, exhibits a glassy
collision, like a pool ball.
Now, let's go in here.
This is the polynorbornene, so
it should still continue to
bounce, because we've raised
its use temperature further
above its glass transition
temperature.
That's not the exciting one.
The exciting one is--
if I can get it out.
What happens to the
polynorbornene?
This is the sad ball, the one
that wouldn't bounce at room
temperature.
By raising its use temperature
above its glass transition
temperature by dunking it
in boiling water, I
get a rubbery response.
[END FILM PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: Super.
OK.
House lights, please.
I don't read well in the dark.
OK.
So I hope you've seen some
examples of how these work.
So now I want to talk a
little bit about the
broader societal issues.
So this, I think, is sort
of a pattern of
adoption of new materials.
You start off with this wonder,
you know, this cool
property that you get
at the lab bench.
You know, when nylon was
invented, it led to
democratization.
Do you realize stockings,
womens' stockings, were only
owned by the wealthy?
Because they were
made of silk.
When they were made
out of nylon, they
became cheap and abundant.
So that changed the way
people dressed.
It changed the way people made
clothing in a way that was
unimaginable before.
So you could, for example, make
a billiard ball, or piano
keys, without killing
an elephant.
You didn't have to use ivory.
You could use polymers.
Huge, huge implications.
So this is one of the first
commercial polymers.
It's phenolic resin, and it's
made by a condensation
polymerization between
carbolic acid and
formaldehyde.
It was called bakelite.
and its corporate symbol was
B with the infinity sign.
Material of a thousand uses.
And this, normally, is--
look at the elaborate
art deco coffeepot.
And this is all-- it's thermal
insulated, and so on.
These are all plumbing parts
made out of bakelite, that
previously would be made out of
many pieces of metal that
had to be machined and
fashioned together.
You could take bakelite powder,
put it into a die,
heat it, and out comes the part,
finished, in one step.
So this has a huge implication
on productivity.
But then, so now we start
talking about substitution,
making the cheap things, the
piano keys, the fork here, and
on and on and on.
But then things that couldn't
exist before.
You know, the movie film.
Look at the steering
wheel here.
There's the, that's indicating
the lady's
stocking, and so on.
This is from Look
magazine, 1940.
People thought these things
were just godsends.
This is Synthetica.
This is a country, and it's got
the province of Cellulose,
Petrolia, Castphenolic
and so on.
This is the 1960s.
This is plastics, the
future has arrived.
It's at a museum in New York.
You're looking at the interior
of a home with furniture built
in, and it's all plastic walls,
and formed, and so on.
I think maybe these guys were
in a drug haze or something.
Those are the windows.
Maybe they thought those
windows were square,
rectilinear, I don't know.
So this is going
way overboard.
And then let me show you
a piece of iconic
film from The Graduate.
You'll see a young
Dustin Hoffman.
He's just come back from getting
a bachelor's degree.
So this could be you someday in
the not too distant future.
And he's at a party that
his parents are
throwing in his honor.
[FILM PLAYBACK]
-We're all so proud of you!
Proud, proud, proud, proud,
proud, proud.
What are you going to do now?
-I was going to go upstairs
for a minute.
-I mean with your future?
Your life?
'Well, that's a little
hard to say.
-Ben.
-Excuse me.
-Mr. McGuire?
-Ben.
-Mr. McGuire.
-Come with me for a minute.
PROFESSOR: See the lipstick?
-I want to talk to you.
Excuse us, Joanne.
PROFESSOR: See, it's the '60s.
They blow off the ladies.
Now the men are going to talk.
-I just want to say
one word to you.
Just one word.
-Yes, sir?
-Are you listening?
-Yes, I am.
-Plastics.
-Exactly how do you mean?
-There's a great future
in plastics.
Think about it.
Will you think about it?
-Yes, I will.
-Enough said.
That's a deal.
[END FILM PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: All right.
So this was 1967, '68.
So what's happened since
then in plastics?
Well, all of these other
considerations about
recyclability, environmental
health and safety issues.
In order to facilitate molding,
when you want to mold
the plastic, to get those bonds
to loosen up a little
bit, we use a chemical known
as a plasticizer.
It's a low molecular weight
polymer that helps the--
it's sort of the equivalent of
putting a little bit of olive
oil in with the pasta, to give
it that freedom to move.
And so this, then, when you sit
in a new car, the new car
smell is the smell of the
plasticizer, which is still
evaporating.
And some of those plasticizers
have molecular architectures
that are similar to hormones
in our bodies.
And so it's not healthy for us
to be breathing this stuff.
So maybe the bright future that
was talked about is not
quite as bright as some people
might have thought it to be.
The other thing is--
you know how I showed you
the plumbing parts?
Well, we started making
all kinds of
things out of polymers.
As a child, I remember
my father bringing
me, one day, a shoe.
The shoe was 100% man-made.
It was all polymer.
And we thought this was
the coolest thing,
because of all man-made.
Of course, there was a
complete reversal.
People said, you know, your foot
can't breathe, and this
is a silly thing to have. But
at the time, we started
making-- and they were ugly.
And you know, for me, if it's
ugly, I don't want to wear
something that's ugly.
So what happened was, we started
making all kinds of
things out of polymers,
or as the public
knows them, as plastics.
And by the mid-'70s, to call
something plastic was to make
a derogatory comment.
It's plastic, it's cheap,
it's shoddy.
So you know, making silk
stockings cheaper as nylon
stockings was good.
But if you get them too
cheap, they're cheap.
See?
So there's an optimum there.
And all of that went
into play.
By the way, how do we get
the word plastic?
It comes from the
Greek plastikos.
And same word as potter.
So when you're working with
clay, you're working with a
plastic medium.
It's deformable,
it's malleable.
There's Samuel Johnson "let
Thy plastick hand." So all
plastics are polymers, but not
all polymers are plastics,
because some polymers
can't be deformed.
If they're below their glass
transition temperature,
they're brittle solids.
All right.
So I've told you enough
about concern.
Let's look at recycling.
In the United States right
now, 100 billion pounds
annually of polymer, 50 million
tons of which 3 to 4
million are recycled.
It's a very low recycle rate.
So this ends up in the waste.
Contrast that to steel.
Steel, we still make 80 million
tons a year of virgin
metal in the United States.
It's still a world-class
steel industry.
You can bet it's world-class.
With our wages and our high
standards, if you're still in
business making steel in
the United States, you
better be damn good.
Very good.
So 80 million tons virgin
metal, 60 million tons
recycled scrap.
We recycle more steel per year
from automobiles than we
consume building new
automobiles.
It's a complete ecology.
And compare that to aluminum.
Aluminum, 4 million tons a year,
1 million tons recycled.
Very high rate on used
beverage containers.
But that's the exception.
Because this was DFE, Designed
For Environment.
The alloy choices were made in
order to facilitate recycling.
So there were certain metals
that were forbidden to go into
the alloy because
they would pose
problems later in recycling.
So there are many ways to get
the same deep-drawing
characteristics.
You know, you make a beverage
can out of a
sheet, and you snap.
Punch down, punch up, there's
no seam on the bottom.
This is made from a single
sheet of metal.
And then a second piece
comes down on the top.
And so this has only aluminum,
silicon, and magnesium.
You could choose other metals,
but with aluminum, silicon,
magnesium, it is recyclable.
But aluminum ladders-- if you're
building an airplane,
let's say you're the chief
purchasing agent for Boeing.
And you've got a choice of
aluminum scrap, which, you
know, people might have thrown
some old fishing weights with
lead in there, and that's now
contaminant in the aluminum.
Or you're going to buy
high-purity virgin metal, and
you're going to bet the
company's future.
What are you going to buy?
You're going to put recycled
metal into an airplane.
Have the thing fall
out of the sky.
No way.
So you have to be careful.
Those alloys, if you take the,
I told you, the door off the
1928 Model-T, and you put it
on a 2010 Taurus, you can't
take the wing off a DC-3
and melt it down
and put it on a 777.
Because the top has an aluminum
alloy with zinc, and
in the bottom one has an
aluminum alloy with copper.
And if you co-melt those,
you'll end up with
intermetallics, and the
alloy is unusable.
So you have to separate them.
Now it's not so simple.
So before you go make
pronouncements saying, yeah,
recycling is great,
think about it.
Follow through.
OK.
If you find this interesting,
and the impact that polymer
had on American culture, this
is a lovely book by Jeffrey
Meikle on polymers
and their use.